- The first time The Voice coaches
were on this show and we played a game
where we had to identify
celebrity voices and I was nuts.
Ariana, wasn't a coach yet.
So she missed out on playing,
but not anymore, people.
I brought her here to kick her behind-
- [Ariana] I'm so excited.
- It's time for another round of...
(drum roll)
♪ Who's that famous voice ♪
♪ Famous voice coaches ♪
- Hit it Jessie.
Maybe our friend from
above can help us out
with this game, maybe.
- [Male Narrator] Hey girl. How you doing?
I'm just over here
jamming to my own music.
(laughing)
- [Male Narrator] And welcome back to LA.
How was New York?
- It was so good.
It was so good.
We're, we're blad...
We're glad to be back.
I'm very, I'm very excited
and competitive right now.
I'm in a competitive mode.
- [Male Narrator] All right.
Calm down, girl. Calm down.
- I know.
- Who is speaking?
- Well what does it sound like?
- [Male Narrator] Well, let me tell you
about this game.
Okay. It's a very simple.
- Did I hear something?
(giggles)
- He sounds just like Morgan Freeman.
- [Male Narrator] I'm not
under the table, girl.
I'm everywhere.
(giggles)
- He's God
- [Male Narrator] Okay.
Now let me tell you about
this game. It's very simple.
Now I'm just going to call
a celebrity on my phone.
Okay, one of my celebrity
friends and if you think you know
the name of the person who answers,
you're going to hit your button. Okay?
Now you are then allowed to
ask the celebrity on the phone
one question before you guess who it is.
If you're right, you get a point.
If you're wrong, the
other person can steal.
Now, if you're both
wrong, the person doing
the impressions will
feel great shame. Okay?
(giggles)
- [Male Narrator] Damn, You
really did them dirty like that,
didn't you? Okay.
Now Kelly is playing for
the left of the audience
(cheers)
- [Male Narrator] Ariana
is playing for the right.
Okay there you go.
A very very cool prize is on the line.
- Okay.
- [Male Narrator] So let me
call up the first celebrity
and see who it is.
- Are you ready?
- [Ariana] No I'm horrible.
- [Liam Neeson] Hello there.
I told you not to call this number.
How did you get this number?
- Oh, where you in a movie called taken?
- [Liam Neeson] I'm quite taken by you.
Yes, that's correct.
- Liam Neeson?
- [Male Narrator] That was unbelievable.
Liam Neeson.
- I'm sorry guys.
- Here's the thing,
that's kind of not fair
because he's kind of one of my crushes.
I love him.
- [Male Narrator] All right,
Kelly, you got one point.
Come on, Ariana.
I know you can do this girl.
- Yeah I don't know.
- [Male Narrator] Alright me call.
That's right, let's give a call
to my next celebrity friend.
- Okay
- [Jeff Goldblum] Oh yes.
Hello and I'm so excited
because oh yes, Kelly, Ariana,
you know, I'm very honored to be here.
(buzzer)
- No, is it?
Oh, if I'm wrong, I'm going to be so mad,
where you in the fly?
- Oh yes, my teeth fell out.
- Jeff Goldblum .
(cheers)
- I was not going to guess that.
Wow, that was amazing .
- [Jeff Goldblum] Its wonderful
and sometimes when I talk,
it sounds like catching a burp,
but before it happens, yes.
- [Male Narrator] Okay.
That's enough, Jeff.
That's enough.
Get off the phone. Okay.
- This is so fun.
- [Male Narrator] This is
the last one for two points.
Two points, now.
This could be it.
(cheers)
- [Male Narrator] Alright let me call
my big time celebrity favorite.
(phone ringing)
- [Vin Diesel] I live my life
for quarter mile at a time.
I don't even know what a quarter mile is.
It doesn't matter whether
you win by an inch or a mile.
- No.
- [Vin Diesel] winning is winning.
I am groot.
- Oh no, no, no.
Oh no, no, no.
He's been on , oh God.
- [Vin Diesel] The most
important thing in life.
- Is it Vin Diesel? - [Vin
Diesel] will always be family.
- No.
(buzzer)
- [Male Narrator] It is Vin Diesel.
(Cheers)
- [Male Narrator] Kelly has won.